our Chinese phones out innovating Apple
well this is the Oppo Find X6 Pro and it
has some incredibly impressive specs and
today we're gonna check out and compare
everything to C does the real world
usage actually match up to the specs
this thing has a 5 000 milliamp hour
battery and it comes with a 100 watt
charger which can charge to 100 three
times faster and as far as wireless
charging it is more than three times
faster compared to the iPhone and that
is one thing I wish the iPhone did
faster design wise the biggest standout
is that massive camera bump if you think
the iPhone sits high off the desk
because of its camera bump look at this
thing it is crazy and you can be careful
with this thing because it's literally
shaving wood off of our desk let's go
ahead and wipe that off but you guys can
see how massive that is compared to the
iPhone's already massive camera cut out
now as far as looks I don't think this
looks particularly bad I've seen way
worse ones but I do like the iPhone's
camera setup better you guys give me
your opinion down below now that is
because it has some massive cameras in
here all three are 50 megapixel but we
will talk about those in just a bit now
one thing I do like is that the back has
this nice satin kind of finish it feels
nice and premium and they also have a
version that has leather on the back
which is so cool and as far as the
comfort and the hand it does feel
Slimmer than the iPhone even though it's
thicker because of its curved Edge
design the screen has quite a bit of a
curve to it it has bigger bezels than I
expected uh compared to a lot of other
Android phones the top and bottom is
flat like the iPhone which means it can
stand on your desk and I also noticed
that the top actually has a speaker
Grille as well so we're going to compare
the speaker quality in just a bit as for
the displays this thing is very
impressive it has a higher resolution
than the iPhone it also has 120 hertz
which makes it super smooth just like
promotion and it goes all the way down
to one Hertz just like the iPhone to
save you battery life now the iPhone has
a shocking 2000 nit Peak brightness
which is insane but the upper oh can
actually do two thousand five hundred
which beats it out but that can
sometimes be exaggerated and the good
thing is it's sunny outside so let's
test it out surprisingly with the mostly
white screen the iPhone gets Brighter
Than This Oppo and then I switched to a
mostly dark screen which typically helps
out the Androids but no the iPhone was
still brighter at 2 000 nits now yes I
did go through the settings I made sure
everything's enabled for the maximum
brightness and the interesting thing is
indoors here now that uh we're limited
with the lighting the iPhone has dimmed
down even if we maxed it out and now the
Oppo allows us to get brighter both for
the full white screen and uh this one
that has a lot less text so in order to
get the full 2500 nits it's gonna have
to be a very small section like with HDR
video now watching this HDR video on
YouTube the iPhone actually looks
brighter and I'm not sure why because we
are playing back at high resolution
brightness is maxed out and as you can
see as soon as I move the menu away it
gets dimmer for some reason now I
lowered the display resolution and
refresh rate thinking maybe that would
help but no the iPhone is still playing
this back better you guys could see how
much brighter those highlights are so
maybe it has to be Dolby Vision specific
uh or something else you guys can let us
know below but it does look like the
iPhone overall does win in terms of
brightness and HDR now I'm really
excited to compare the speakers and the
Oppo has Dolby Atmos with this
intelligent profile that will adapt so
let's see how these dual speakers work
[Music]
foreign
now the Apple definitely sounds good and
it might be slightly louder in the high
frequencies but the iPhone has better
bass and with that the one thing I
noticed that you might not through
YouTube is the iPhone has a nice even
sound on both sides whereas the Oppo
even with this cutout right here you
definitely hear a lot more volume from
that bottom speaker so it's not as
immersive and now let's get into
performance one interesting thing about
that find X6 Pro is that it has 12 gigs
of RAM compared to six but it showed up
as 16 because you can actually expand
your RAM all the way up to add an
additional eight using the internal
storage so I wanted to test out just how
fast is the 256 gig ssds with this one
compared to apple so let's run this holy
moly that is a huge difference now I do
have more stuff on the iPhone and you
guys see the full specs here but the
read speeds are more than twice as fast
and that's what matters you're going to
be pulling data from the memory as RAM
and then the write speeds there's a
massive difference this Oppo is actually
faster in terms of read speeds than
buying an M2 MacBook Air getting into
CPU performance with a newly updated
geekbench 6 we have the a16 bionic
versus the Snapdragon 8 Gen 2 with
really good cooling so let's go ahead
and run the CPU Benchmark all right we
have our results and I want to show you
guys that high performance mode is on
and look at that we have a big
difference especially in terms of single
core where the iPhone has a 67 percent
higher score that is crazy and in terms
of multi-core we have about a 22
difference in favor of the iPhone so
both are four nanometer but the iPhone
is still the champ now what about graph
ethics performance this is where that
new Snapdragon should be very good I'm
gonna run the compute Benchmark so many
apps now are using Graphics to do the
processing and wow the iPhone smokes the
Oppo in terms of compute both Vulcan and
opencl now I think that this might not
be cross compatible I'm really not sure
because the results are very very low so
let's go ahead and close that and let's
do a gaming test with 3dmarks Wildlife
extreme using the unlimited mode that
way there is no difference in terms of
resolution the apple is so much faster
at loading this up it is crazy and look
at that the Oppo takes the win 21.5
frames per second compared to 17.8 about
21 22 faster and it has better cooling
as well so if you're in a gaming this
thing does take the win now what about
these cameras the iPhone has one camera
that's 48 megapixel and the rest are 12
while the Oppo all three on the back are
50 megapixels which I really appreciate
and then on the front we have 12
megapixel compared to 32. let me know
which one looks better to you but
zooming in here I do see more detail on
the Oppo shot now Apple says there is no
main camera they're all identical great
quality but the standard wide lens has a
one inch sensor which is huge so it
should do a great job in low light I
took a shot of a deem right here let me
go into his face you guys let me know
which one do you think looks better in a
low light situation is just all the
stacking Apple does or the larger sensor
now here's the shot outside we have 48
megapixels compared to 50. I did have
high res mode turned on and it looks
like the iPhone shows quite a bit more
detail than the Oppo at 50 megapixel
mode as for the ultra wide the iPhone
could only do 2 12 megapixel compared to
50 I see the apple has a lot more
flaring and zooming in here honestly I
am not seeing a lot of extra detail that
you would expect I do like that this
Ultra wide shot of a deem has a better
white balance is not as warm but as far
as HDR but as far as HDR the Oppo blew
out that light while the iPhone was able
to preserve that now as far as Zoom
shots we have that impressive telescopic
camera and they also have a 6X mode that
is actually a crop but one weird thing
is if you're in the high-res 50
megapixel mode it limits you to only 3x
instead of giving you more zoom so when
this 3x shot I do see that we have more
detail with the Oppo it's definitely
cleaner and using 15x which is the
maximum the iPhone can do the Oppo
definitely looks nicer with that
telescopic camera sharper less noise
better contrast but one thing that
surprised me zooming in to about 80x and
then having to craft the iPhone's 15.
the iPhone still looks surprisingly
close and then with a full 120 times
Zoom which is insane we get that shot on
the Oppo and taking the iPhone's 15x
zooming it all the way in I don't know I
would say the iPhone looks better both
look terrible but this does not look
like it's usable 120x looks bad so I'm
really surprised by the iPhone's deep
Fusion technology that it beat it out in
a lot of those you guys let me know your
thoughts on those photos and if you guys
want us to do a blind camera comparison
with the Oppo the iPhone 14 pro Max and
the s23 ultra you guys can hit that like
button comment below if you guys want us
to make one of those so to answer the
original questions are Chinese
smartphones out innovating Apple well
the specs are definitely impressive and
I would love to have have faster
charging especially faster wireless
charging and since Apple charges us a
hundred bucks to upgrade the storage or
256 it should be faster but with that
said in a lot of different ways the
iPhone still beats it out their ability
to have great software for the camera's
diffusion and their ability to make
their own chips and optimize their
Hardware together and of course we have
the dynamic Island which is also unique
they are still keeping up and doing a
great job but you let me know your
thoughts down below click that Circle
above to subscribe check out one of
those videos right over there this has
been Max and I'll see you in the next
one
[Music]
all right